Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. From its ranch and farmland outskirts, to its humble, close-knit community of several thousand residents, the township of Cisco is emblematic of traditional rural Texas. Its quaint character hasn't changed much over the decades, except briefly during the 1920s, when the population more than tripled to nearly 8,000 people.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。思科镇从其牧场和田园边缘，到其拥有数千名居民的简朴紧密社区，是传统德克萨斯州乡村的象征。几十年来，它古雅的特色并没有太大变化，只是在20世纪20年代短暂地经历过一次变化，当时人口激增了两倍多，达到了近8,000人。
At the time, Cisco was nested on the edge of one of the United States' most productive oil fields, prompting an influx of newcomers hoping to make a fortune from the black gold, or Texas tea as it was known. The oil boom brought prosperity to Cisco and its residents, and the town soon boasted a city charter and a new railroad. Although the height of the boom had passed by the late 1920s, by which point many had obtained the riches they sought, others continued to find new and innovative ways to keep making money.
当时，思科坐落在美国最富饶的油田之一的边缘，吸引了大批新来者，他们希望能从这些黑金（当时被称为德克萨斯茶）中发财。石油繁荣为思科及其居民带来了繁荣，这座城镇很快就拥有了城市特许状和一条新铁路。尽管到20世纪20年代末，石油繁荣的高峰已经过去，当时许多人已经获得了他们追求的财富，但其他人仍在继续寻找新的创新方式来赚钱。
It was the era of prohibition, but in Texas, opponents of the alcohol ban were in control of the government and refused to enforce its policies. The South became a major producer and distributor of illicit whiskey, better known as Moonshine, and bootlegging was favorably tolerated. At the heart of Cisco's business center was a wide paved boulevard lined with sturdy red brick architecture that housed typical small-town fare, a post office, hotel, antique stores, and a bank. In December 1927, the boulevard sparkled in green, red, and gold for Christmas.
那是禁酒令时期，但在德克萨斯州，反对禁酒令的人控制了政府，并拒绝执行其政策。南方成为非法威士忌（更为人所知的名字是私酿酒）的主要生产和分销地，走私酒受到了宽容对待。思科商业中心的中心是一条宽阔的铺面大道，两旁是坚固的红砖建筑，里面有典型的小镇设施，包括邮局、酒店、古董店和银行。1927年12月，这条大道为圣诞节闪烁着绿、红、金三色光芒。
Creative decor was prominently displayed in storefronts, and the streets were filled with children who had been released from school for the holiday break. On Friday, December 23, two days before Christmas, Cisco's children were alerted to a very special arrival in town. Santa Claus in his red suit, silvery hair, and matching curly beard was making his way down the main street. Children mobbed the beloved character, while some adults noted this Santa was significantly thinner than usual.
创意装饰在店面显眼处展示，街上挤满了因学校放圣诞假而出来玩的孩子们。12月23日星期五，圣诞节前两天，思科的孩子们接到通知，镇上将迎来一位非常特殊的访客。穿着红衣服、有着银色头发和相配的卷曲胡须的圣诞老人正沿着主街走来。孩子们蜂拥而上围住这个深受喜爱的角色，而一些成年人则注意到这个圣诞老人明显比平时瘦。
His trademark red robe looked cheap, it was clearly homemade, and barely covered his street clothes underneath. He carried neither sweets to give the children, nor a collection tin for charity. Instead, he held an empty brown burlap sack with Idaho potatoes stenciled across the front. Santa paused before a young boy and shook his hand, asking, Well, little man, what do you want for Christmas? The boy wanted to become a football player when he grew up, and requested a football from a store across the road.
他标志性的红袍看起来很廉价，显然是自制的，几乎盖不住里面穿的街头服装。他既没有带给孩子们的糖果，也没有带用于慈善的募捐罐。相反，他拿着一个空的棕色麻布袋，袋子正面印有爱达荷土豆的字样。圣诞老人停在一个小男孩面前，和他握手，问道：“好吧，小家伙，你圣诞节想要什么？”男孩长大后想成为一名足球运动员，并要求得到路对面一家商店的一个足球。
He grabbed Santa's hand and tried to drag him towards the shop, but Santa shook him off, explaining he couldn't deviate from his path. He told the boy to point the gift out to his parents, and that Father Christmas would surely leave it under the tree for him. Santa hastened his steps, but couldn't shake the crowd of children that was now following him. Some expressed their disappointment that he wasn't handing out candy or small gifts, while the older children declared that he wasn't the real Santa at all.
他抓住圣诞老人的手，试图把他拉向商店，但圣诞老人甩开了他，解释说他不能偏离路线。他告诉男孩把礼物指给父母看，圣诞老人肯定会把它留在树下。圣诞老人加快了脚步，但还是甩不掉现在正跟着他的一群孩子。有些人对没有分发糖果或小礼物表示失望，而稍大一点的孩子则宣称他根本不是真正的圣诞老人。
As he entered the front door of the first National Bank of Cisco, which sat on the corner of Main Street and a narrow alleyway, the grown-ups chuckled that even Saint Nick had a banking business to tend to during the holiday season. When the bell over the bank's door rang, cashier Alec Spears looked up from tending to a customer and called out a cheery, Hello Santa? Without a word, the man in the red suit made his way to the desk in the middle of the lobby, ignoring the children still following behind. Thinking perhaps Saint Nick hadn't heard him, Alec's kept up the Christmas cheer with
当他走进位于主街和一条狭窄小巷拐角处的思科第一国民银行前门时，大人们笑着说，连圣尼古拉在假期里也有银行业务要处理。当银行门上的铃铛响起时，出纳员亚历克·斯皮尔斯（Alec Spears）从照顾客户中抬起头，欢快地喊道：“你好，圣诞老人？”那个穿红衣服的人一言不发，径直走向大厅中央的桌子，无视后面仍然跟着的孩子们。亚历克以为圣尼古拉可能没听到他，于是继续保持着圣诞节的欢乐气氛
another call of, Hello Santa Claus? Again, there was no response from Saint Nick. The other bank patrons were paying such close attention to him that they barely noticed when the bell above the door rang out again as three men entered. The trio quietly drew pistols out from beneath their bulky coats and yelled, Stick em up, this is a robbery. In the United States, the 1920s had been deemed the golden age of crime. By 1926, many parts of Texas showed the early signs of entering into a depression, and desperation
又喊了一声：“你好，圣诞老人？”圣尼古拉依然没有任何回应。其他银行顾客对他的关注如此之高，以至于当门上的铃铛再次响起，三名男子走进来时，他们几乎没有注意到。这三名男子悄悄地从臃肿的外套下掏出手枪，大喊道：“举起手来，这是抢劫。”在美国，20世纪20年代被誉为犯罪的黄金时代。到1926年，德克萨斯州的许多地区显示出进入萧条期的早期迹象，绝望情绪
from those who had lost everything caused the rapid increase in the number of bank robberies. Between 1920 and 1929, insurance companies reported that property crime from bank robberies to drugstore holdups increased by 1700%. Banks in rural areas were particularly vulnerable. When robberies grew to a frequency of three to four per week, the Texas Bankers Association established the popular, yet controversial, dead bank robber reward program. As part of the scheme, anyone who shot and killed a robber during the act of holding up a bank was rewarded with $5,000 cash, no questions asked.
来自失去一切的人导致银行抢劫案数量急剧增加。在1920年至1929年期间，保险公司报告称，从银行抢劫到药店抢劫的财产犯罪增加了1700%。农村地区的银行尤其脆弱。当抢劫频率增加到每周三到四次时，德克萨斯州银行家协会设立了广受欢迎却又备受争议的“击毙银行劫匪悬赏计划”。作为该计划的一部分，任何人在抢劫银行的过程中开枪打死劫匪，都将获得5,000美元现金奖励，无需多问。
The bounty would not be paid in the event the robber was merely injured. The program garnered considerable media attention, and while some viewed it as an extreme measure, many celebrated it as an effective remedy where the culprits got what they deserved. Justice Ben Lindsay, a progressive judge and social reformer based in Denver, Colorado, was firmly against the dead bank robber reward program, and stated, I am amazed that such a conservative group in Texas as the bankers would lend themselves to a practice that is so fraught with consequences to the orderly processes of justice. The danger lies in the possibility that some grotesque mockery of justice may result,
如果劫匪仅受伤，则不予支付赏金。该计划获得了相当大的媒体关注，虽然有些人认为这是一项极端措施，但许多人将其庆祝为一种有效的救济手段，让罪犯得到了应有的下场。本·林德西（Ben Lindsay）法官是科罗拉多州丹佛市的一位进步派法官和社会改革家，他坚决反对击毙银行劫匪悬赏计划，并表示：“我很惊讶，德克萨斯州的银行家这样一个保守的群体，竟然会参与一种对有序的司法进程带来如此严重后果的做法。危险在于可能会产生某种对正义的怪诞嘲弄，”
especially if some peace officer in his zeal to collect $5,000 should shoot down an innocent man. I see no reason why the bankers should set themselves up as Lord High executioners. Justice Justice Lindsay predicted that wasn't long until flaws in the system began to emerge. Few robbers were killed during banking hours or in the actual commission of a robbery. Instead, most of the shootings occurred at night and under suspicious circumstances. Many were carried out by local police officers who arrived at the scene after receiving alleged tip-offs. In one incident, four Mexican laborers were picked up by two men, including a deputy sheriff, under the pretense of offering them work.
“特别是如果某个治安官为了收集5,000美元而热心地枪杀了一个无辜的人。我看不出银行家有什么理由把自己打扮成大法官。”林德西法官预测，该系统的漏洞开始显现只是时间问题。在银行营业时间内或在实际抢劫过程中被杀的劫匪很少。相反，大多数枪击事件发生在夜间且情况可疑的情况下。许多枪击事件是由当地警察实施的，他们在接到所谓的举报后赶到现场。在起事件中，两名男子（包括一名副警长）以提供工作为借口，带走了四名墨西哥劳工。
The workers were driven to a rural town and were told to wait by the local bank branch. Shortly afterwards, the church across the street mysteriously caught fire, capturing the attention of the town's folk. In the ensuing panic, the deputy and his friend rushed upon the four Mexican workers and started shooting, killing two and seriously wounding a third. The two gunmen alleged that the workers were preparing to rob the bank. The surviving victims testified that the entire scenario was a setup, concocted by the deputy and his friend to collect the $5,000 banked rubber bounty. They were prosecuted for the crime, but there were many more thwarted robberies where the bandits did not live to dispute the shooter's version of events.
这些工人被驱车带到一个乡村小镇，并被告知在当地银行分行旁等候。不久之后，街对面的教堂神秘起火，吸引了镇上居民的注意力。在随后的混乱中，副警长和他的朋友冲向四名墨西哥工人并开始开枪，打死两人，重伤第三人。两名枪手声称这些工人正准备抢劫银行。幸存的受害者作证说，整个场景是一个圈套，由副警长和他的朋友精心策划，以收集5,000美元的击毙银行劫匪赏金。他们因罪行而被起诉，但还有更多被挫败的抢劫案，劫匪没有活下来去反驳枪手对事件的说法。
Since the introduction of the rewards program, losses faced by the banks had decreased significantly, even after factoring in the bounty payments. As such, the Texas Bankers Association refused to withdraw the program, but an amendment was made to the policy wording to clarify the reward was only available in the case of lawful shootings, which occurred in daylight during the actual commission of a robbery. Shortly before the man in the Santa Claus suit walked into Cisco's first national bank, he caught the attention of six-year-old Francis Blasingame. The child begged her mother to take her to meet him, and though Mrs. Blasingame was reluctant,
自悬赏计划推出以来，银行面临的损失显着减少，即使在计入赏金支出之后也是如此。因此，德克萨斯州银行家协会拒绝撤销该计划，但对政策措辞进行了修改，以澄清悬赏仅适用于在白天实际抢劫过程中发生的合法枪击事件。就在身穿圣诞老人服装的男子走进思科第一国民银行之前，他吸引了六岁的弗朗西丝·布拉辛盖姆（Francis Blasingame）的注意。小女孩乞求母亲带她去见他，尽管布拉辛盖姆夫人有些不情愿，
Francis wore her down and the pair headed into the bank. By the time they entered, Santa had filled his burlap sack with cash and had taken possession of the bank's CULT-45 automatic pistol, which was stored on the premises for protection. There were also several other handheld firearms secured in the black belt around his waist. Upon realizing what was happening, Mrs. Blasingame turned to exit the front door, but saw it was now guarded by one of Santa's armed assistants. As she was somewhat familiar with the layout of the bank, she took advantage of the commotion and ushered her daughter through the bookkeeper's room, where she knew of a door that led on to the neighboring alleyway.
弗朗西丝软磨硬泡，两人最终走进了银行。当她们进去时，圣诞老人已经把麻布袋装满了现金，并拿到了银行的CULT-45自动手枪，这把枪原本存放在店内用于防身。他腰间的黑色皮带上也固定着几把其他手持火器。意识到发生了什么后，布拉辛盖姆夫人转身准备从前门出去，却发现门现在由圣诞老人的一个持枪助手把守。由于她对银行的布局略知一二，她利用混乱将女儿带过了簿记员室，她知道那里有一扇通往相邻小巷的门。
The robbers warned her to stop, but she shielded Francis with her own body and the pair managed to escape. Once safely outside, Mrs. Blasingame screamed at Francis to run and take cover. She then raced up the alley and threw a vacant lot, yelling that the bank was being robbed. She headed straight to the police station, where Chief of Police, G.E. Bit Bedford, wasted no time in collecting a riot gun and two officers, R.T. Reddies and George Carmichael. When local men spotted the police racing towards the bank, they too sprang into action. The scenario presented an opportunity that fit within the terms of the dead bank robber reward program, offering the potential for someone to earn $20,000 should all four bandits be shot dead.
劫匪警告她停下，但她用自己的身体护住弗朗西丝，两人设法逃脱了。一旦安全到达外面，布拉辛盖姆夫人就大喊让弗朗西丝快跑并寻找掩护。然后她冲进小巷，穿过一块空地，大喊银行正在被抢劫。她径直前往警察局，局长G.E.“比特”贝德福德（G.E. Bit Bedford）毫不迟疑地拿了一把防暴枪和两名警官R.T.雷迪斯（R.T. Reddies）和乔治·卡迈克尔（George Carmichael）。当当地男子看到警察冲向银行时，他们也立即行动起来。这个场景提供了一个符合击毙银行劫匪悬赏计划条款的机会，如果所有四名匪徒都被枪杀，任何人都有可能赚取20,000美元。
The local men retrieved firearms from their vehicles and to those who were unarmed raced to a nearby hardware store, buying out the store's stock of guns and ammunition. Chief Bedford, a veteran police officer who was tall and strong in stature, went to the front of the bank and directed his deputies to cover the back door. He was quickly joined by such a large number of armed citizens that the town's postmaster began marshalling them into an orderly line, brokering deals to split the loot if anyone made a kill. Inside the bank, Santa had finished loading up more than $12,000 in cash and started gathering up the checks, bonds and other valuables held within the vault, when suddenly a gunshot rang out.
当地男子从他们的车里取回枪械，没有武器的人则冲向附近的一家五金店，买光了该店的枪支和弹药库存。贝德福德局长是一名身材高大强壮的资深警官，他走到银行前门，指挥他的副手们守住后门。很快有大量武装市民加入他的行列，以至于镇上的邮政局长开始将他们编成整洁的队伍，并商量如果有人击毙匪徒就平分战利品。在银行内部，圣诞老人已经装好了超过12,000美元的现金，并开始收集金库里持有的支票、债券和其他贵族物品，突然一声枪响。
Nobody was quite sure who fired the first shot or why, but it set off a chain reaction. Bullets flew from the street into the bank, ricocheting off walls and furniture. When a bullet struck one of the robbers through the front window, the four offenders quickly gathered the terrified customers and children around themselves and ushered their human shield towards the rear door. They emerged into the alleyway, exchanging gunfire with police as they went. Choosing two hostages to leave with them, 12-year-old Laverne Coma and 10-year-old Emma Mae Robertson, they made their way into their getaway vehicle that was parked nearby, a Navy Buick with wood trim, and sped off. Officer Reddy's corralled Cisco's man and boys
没有人能确定是谁开了第一枪，也不知道为什么，但这引发了一连串的反应。子弹从街上飞进银行，在墙壁和家具上反弹。当一颗子弹穿过前窗击中其中一名劫匪时，四名罪犯迅速将惊恐的顾客和儿童聚集在自己周围，并将他们的肉盾推向后门。他们出现在小巷里，一路上与警察交火。他们选择了两名人质带走——12岁的拉韦恩·科马（Laverne Coma）和10岁的埃玛·梅·罗伯逊（Emma Mae Robertson），坐上停在附近的一辆带木饰面的海军蓝别克逃跑车，疾驰而去。雷迪斯警官集结了思科的男人们和男孩们
and formed an impromptu posse. Jumping into vehicles and on horseback, they started in pursuit of the Buick, initiating the largest manhunt in the history of Texas. Several of the robbers were nursing injuries and one was bleeding profusely all over the Buick's plush gray upholstery. The group yelled at one another as their two young hostages remained silent. Of the pair, Laverne Coma had reason to be especially fearful. She had visited the bank that day hoping to withdraw some of her hard-earned money to buy Christmas presents for her family, and although he was still wearing his scrappy disguise, she had recognized Santa. Laverne's mother had bought a cafe from his mother a year prior, and he still dined at the establishment
并组建了一支临时搜捕队。他们跳上汽车和马背，开始追捕别克车，拉开了德克萨斯州历史上最大规模搜捕行动的序幕。几名劫匪受了伤，其中一人在别克车毛绒灰色的内饰上流血不止。这群人互相大喊大叫，而他们两名年轻的人质则保持沉默。在这两人中，拉韦恩·科马有理由感到格外害怕。她那天去银行是希望能取出一些辛苦赚来的钱为家人买圣诞礼物，尽管他身上还穿着破烂的伪装，但她认出了圣诞老人。拉韦恩的母亲一年前从他母亲那里买下了一家咖啡馆，而他至今仍在那家店里用餐
regularly. Santa's real name was Marshall Ratliff. Ratliff had been a troublemaker since childhood. He was spoiled by his mother who dismissed his misbehaviour as youthful hijinks, even when his actions led to him being expelled from school in the 9th grade. He went to work on a farm, plowing, howling, and pulling cotton, but quickly became resentful of the backbreaking work. He then joined forces with his older brother Lee and turned to the bootlegging business. Although Ratliff's reputation as a troublemaker preceded him, many couldn't help but be charmed by the 21-year-old's good looks, sense of humour, and impressive singing voice. His friends found him to be fun and generous and always happy to
经常去。圣诞老人的真名是马歇尔·拉特利夫（Marshall Ratliff）。拉特利夫从小就是一个令人头疼的麻烦制造者。他被母亲惯坏了，母亲将他的不良行为视为年轻人的恶作剧，甚至当他的行为导致他在9年级被学校开除时也是如此。他去农场工作，犁地、锄地、摘棉花，但很快就对这种繁重的体力劳动心生怨恨。后来，他与哥哥李（Lee）联手，转向了走私酒生意。尽管拉特利夫作为麻烦制造者的名声在外，但许多人还是被这个21岁年轻人出众的外表、幽默感和令人印象深刻的歌声所吸引。他的朋友们发现他既有趣又慷慨，总是乐于
share a bit of homemade liquor with them. Ratliff looked after his mother and sisters, but lost all pleasantries around those he didn't like. Although he found the bootlegging business to be easier than farming, Ratliff yearned to make more money with less effort. He aspired to be like his neighbour, Old Man Yule, who always seemed to be flush with cash despite never having a job. When a young Ratliff asked the old man how he did it, Yule confided that he and his brother had successfully robbed a bank when they were young, setting them up for life. Inspired by Yule's story, in 1926, Marshall and Lee Ratliff held up a bank in Valera, Coleman County. They fled with more than $3,000 but were later apprehended by the police.
与他们分享一些自制的烈酒。拉特利夫照顾他的母亲和姐妹，但在他不喜欢的人面前却失去了所有的礼貌。尽管拉特利夫发现走私酒生意比耕作更容易，但他渴望用更少的努力赚更多的钱。他渴望像他的邻居“老尤尔”（Old Man Yule）那样，后者虽然从来没有工作，但似乎总是腰缠万贯。当年轻的拉特利夫问老人他是怎么做到的时，尤尔吐露说，他和他的兄弟年轻时成功抢劫了一家银行，这让他们一生衣食无忧。受尤尔故事的启发，1926年，马歇尔和李·拉特利夫抢劫了瓦莱拉科尔曼县的一家银行。他们携带着3,000多美元逃跑，但后来被警方逮捕。
One of the officers responsible for the young men's capture, conviction, and imprisonment was Police Chief Bedford, who had leapt into action upon learning that the first National Bank of Cisco was being held up. For their involvement in the Valera robbery, the Ratliff brothers were reached sentenced to 18 years in the Huntsville State Penitentiary, the oldest state prison in Texas. Citizens who believed the boys deserved a second chance made an appeal to the governor, which was sweetened by a donation from their mother, and they were subsequently granted a pardon. Upon their release from prison, Marshall and Lee Ratliff went straight back to bootlegging. Lee swore off robbing banks, but his brother had gone over everything that went wrong during
负责抓捕、定罪和监禁这些年轻人的警官之一是贝德福德警察局长，他在得知思科第一国民银行遭到抢劫时立即采取了行动。由于参与瓦莱拉抢劫案，拉特利夫兄弟被判处在德克萨斯州最古老的州立监狱——亨茨维尔州立监狱服刑18年。那些认为这些男孩应该得到第二次机会的市民向州长提出了上诉，并在他们母亲的捐款支持下得到了缓刑，随后他们被赦免了。出狱后，马歇尔和李·拉特利夫重操旧业，继续走私酒。李发誓不再抢劫银行，但他弟弟仔细琢磨了第一次抢劫中出错的所有环节，认为自己已经把一切都想明白了。他物色到了一个新的目标，掌握着某家银行的秘密情报，这将使他能够为参与者策划一场顺利、利润丰厚的大劫案。他只需要几个同伙。
their first attempt and thought he had it all figured out. He had a new target in mind, possessing secret knowledge about one particular bank that would allow him to pull off a smooth, lucrative heist for those involved. All he needed were some partners. While looking for work in the Wichita Falls oil fields, Marshall Ratliff was residing in a modest where he bumped into a familiar face from his time in Huntsville Penitentiary. Robert Hill, who was orphaned at age 10, had been convicted for holding up a tailor shop. He insisted he had taken the fall for others involved in the crime, as he had no wife or family depending on him. Ratliff and Hill had bonded in prison, and as free men,
在威奇托福尔斯油田寻找工作期间，马歇尔·拉特利夫住在一个简陋的地方，在那里他遇到了一个在亨茨维尔监狱时期的老熟人。罗伯特·힐（Robert Hill），10岁成孤儿，曾因抢劫一家裁缝店而被定罪。他坚称自己替犯罪的其他同伙顶了罪，因为他没有需要抚养的妻子或家人。拉特利夫和希尔在监狱里结下了深厚的友谊，重获自由后，他们在油田一起找到了零工。两人不久后遇到了另一名雷克斯·亨茨维尔的囚犯亨利·赫尔姆斯（Henry Helms）。赫尔姆斯30多岁，比拉特利夫和希尔大得多。作为一名牧师的儿子，他在童年时期就误入歧途，并且再也没有回到正道上来。凭借着长长的犯罪记录和令人胆寒的体形，大多数人都尽量避开赫尔姆斯。他有四个孩子，还有一个即将出生，一直在油田工作以谋生，但他对能增加收入的其他想法持开放态度。这三名男子成为了朋友，搬出了他们与其他油田工人合住的简陋宿舍，搬到了威奇托福尔斯一间舒适得多的寄宿公寓。
they found casual work together in the oil fields. The pair soon encountered another Rex Huntsville inmate, Henry Helms. Aged in his 30s, Helms was considerably older than Ratliff and Hill. The son of a reverend, he had gone off the rails during his childhood and had never managed to get back on the straight and narrow. With a long criminal record and intimidating physical presence, most people went out of their way to avoid Helms. He had four children with another on the way and had been working in the oil fields to earn a living, but was opened to other ideas that would increase his income. The three men became friends and moved out of the basic bunkhouse they shared with the
这栋房子由赫尔姆斯的一个熟人经营，她是一个名叫米奇·特拉德（Midge Tellard）的随和女人，热情健谈，一点也不被这些前罪犯吓倒。尽管她的丈夫不赞成这些男人，但米奇对待他们就像对待自己的亲生儿子一样。马歇尔·拉特利夫很快告诉希尔和赫尔姆斯，他有一个宏伟的计划，要在繁忙的圣诞期间抢劫思科第一国民银行，当时银行里有巨额资金。拉特利夫熟悉该建筑的布局，知道它有一个后门，直接通往一条小巷，这将是一条简单的逃跑路线。他相信
other oil field workers and into a much more comfortable boarding house in Wichita Falls. The house was run by one of Helms's acquaintances, an easy-going woman named Midge Tellard, who was warm, chatty, and not at all intimidated by the ex-convicts. Although her husband disapproved of the men, Midge treated them as though they were her own sons. Marshall Ratliff soon told Hill and Helms that he had a grand plan to rob the first National Bank of Cisco during the busy Christmas period, when the bank held a large sum of money. Ratliff was familiar with the building's layout and knew it had a rear door that opened directly into an alleyway, which would make for a straightforward escape route. He believed the
抢劫将会快速而轻松，因为他们只需从前门进去，用枪指着一名员工直到他们交出钱，然后悄悄从后门溜走。其他人对这个想法并不那么热心，考虑到拉特利夫之前曾因抢劫银行被抓，而且只是由于他母亲及时提供的金钱贿赂才得以重获自由。他们还提醒他注意击毙银行劫匪可获得5,000美元的悬赏。但拉特利夫对他的计划仍然坚信不疑，指出所有银行都投了保，真正专业的银行劫匪很少被枪杀。他相信普通市民没有勇气与武装匪徒作对，并说道：“你拿一个精明的银行家，用枪指着他，他不会争辩，他只会把钱铲出来，直到你喊停。”
robbery would be quick and easy, as all they had to do was go in through the front door, point a gun at an employee until they handed over the money, then slip quietly out the back. The other men were not quite as enthusiastic about the idea, considering that Ratliff had previously been caught robbing a bank and was only a free man thanks to a timely financial bribe produced by his mother. They also reminded him about the $5,000 reward on offer for anyone who killed a bank robber. But Ratliff remained convinced of his plan, pointing out that all banks were insured and that real professional bank robbers rarely got shot. He believed that regular citizens weren't brave enough to mess with armed bandits, saying, You take a smart banker and poke a gun
经过一番劝说，赫尔姆斯同意参与这起犯罪。希尔仍然犹豫不决，但当拉特利夫告诉他这次行动每人至少能赚10,000美元时，他的兴趣增加了。三人花了很多个晚上来策划他们的袭击。他们信任米奇·特利特，请她帮忙购买他们不想被人看到购买的物资，包括绷带、碘酒和路上的零食。米奇没有问任何问题，买下了他们要求的一切。拉特利夫确切地知道每个人在抢劫过程中需要在哪里，以控制整个
at him, he won't argue, he'll just shovel it out till you yell quit. After some convincing, Helms agreed to participate in the crime. Hill remained hesitant, but when Ratliff told him the job would earn at least $10,000 a piece, his interest grew. The trio spent many evenings planning their attack. They put their trust in Midge Tellit by asking her to purchase supplies they didn't want to be witnessed buying, including bandages, iodine and snack foods for the road. Without asking any questions, Midge bought everything they requested. Ratliff knew exactly where everyone needed to be during the robbery in order to secure the entire
银行，而他则从保险箱和金库中收集战利品。他们只需要再找一个人。赫尔姆斯找到了这个工作的完美人选，另一个有枪械使用经验的前罪犯。虽然这些人并不打算枪杀任何人，但他们在携带武器时希望显得自己知道自己在做什么。随着选定日期的临近，这位准第四名船员因流感卧床不起。赫尔姆斯和希尔将此视为一个不祥之兆，建议将抢劫推迟到新年，但拉特利夫态度坚决，因为他确定该银行将在圣诞节前关门前的最后一个星期五拥有最多的钱。赫尔姆斯建议他的姻亲路易斯·戴维斯（Louis Davis）可能很合适。戴维斯从未
bank, while he collected the hall from the safe and vault. They just needed one more person. Helms had the perfect man for the job, another ex-con who was experienced with firearms. Although the men didn't plan on shooting anybody, they wanted to appear as though they knew what they were doing when carrying their weapons. As their chosen date approached, the would-be fourth member of the crew became bedridden with the flu. Helms and Hill took this as an omen, suggesting they delayed the robbery until the new year, but Ratliff was adamant, as he had determined that the bank would contain the most money on the last Friday before it closed for Christmas. Helms suggested his in-law, Louis Davis, might fit the bill. Davis had never been
惹上过法律麻烦，但这个年轻人有一个大家庭要养活，赫尔姆斯确信他会渴望这个机会，为他们未来几年的生活提供保障。拉特利夫和希尔对戴维斯缺乏犯罪经验感到犹豫，但由于他们选择不多，他们同意与他见面。戴维斯看起来足够随和和可靠，能够完成这项工作，于是被拉入了他们的计划。1927年12月22日星期四，即抢劫前一天，拉特利夫还有最后两个问题要解决。虽然其他三人在思科从未有过任何勾当，但拉特利夫的脸在镇上广为人知，包括警察局长。米奇·特利特一直在
in trouble with the law before, but the young man had a large family to support, and Helms was certain he would be eager for the opportunity to provide for them for years to come. Ratliff and Hill were hesitant about Davis's lack of criminal experience, but as they were running out of options, they agreed to meet him. Davis seemed agreeable and dependable enough to get the job done, and so was brought in on their plan. On Thursday December 22, 1927, the day before the robbery, Ratliff had two final issues to sort out. While the other three men had never had any business in Cisco before, Ratliff's face was well known around town, including by the police chief. Midge Tellit had been
为假期缝制一套圣诞老人服装，拉特利夫开口借用。米奇欣然答应。计划的最后一部分是寻找一辆逃跑车辆。这几个人都没有车，于是他们在当地的居民区四处游荡，直到找到一辆海军蓝别克汽车，车钥匙插在点火开关里，油箱满满的。他们把它开回了寄宿公寓，并花了一晚上的剩余时间，靠喝电解质酒（一种强力的私酿威士忌）来壮胆。在1927年12月23日的清晨，四人乘别克车出发，踏上了前往思科的150英里旅程，
sewing a Santa costume for the holiday season, and Ratliff asked to borrow it. Midge happily obliged. The final part of the plan was to source a getaway vehicle. None of the men owned a car, so they roamed the local neighborhoods until they found a navy blue Buick with the keys in the ignition and a full tank of gas. They drove it back to the boarding house and spent the remainder of the evening bolstering their courage by getting drunk on electrolytine, a powerful bootleg whiskey. In the early hours of December 23, 1927, the four men set off in the Buick for the 150-mile journey to Cisco,
避免穿过可能引起注意的大城镇。当他们接近目的地时，拉特利夫再次详细梳理了计划。他知道那天可能值班的思科第一国民银行员工的名字，并推测亚历克·斯皮尔斯会坐在出纳桌前，朱厄尔·波（Jewel Poe）会坐在第一个出纳笼子里。他预计他们到达时银行里不会有超过几个顾客。戴维斯对他们带来的手枪和弹药数量感到非常不适，但拉特利夫向他保证枪支大多只是做样子的，极
avoiding driving through larger towns where they might garner attention. As they neared their destination, Ratliff went over the plan in detail once again. He knew the names of the first national bank employees likely to be on duty that day, and presumed Alec Spears would be at the cashier's desk, and Jewel Poe would be inside the first teller's cage. He didn't anticipate there would be more than a couple of customers inside the bank upon their arrival. Davis was extremely uncomfortable with the number of pistols and ammunition they had brought along, but Ratliff reassured him the guns were mostly for show, and it was highly
不可能要求他们开枪。银行出纳员亚历克·斯皮尔斯曾说过，他绝不会为了在抢劫中当英雄而冒受伤的风险。这群人在中午前不久到达了思科。拉特利夫指挥希尔将别克车停在小巷尽头附近，并指出了他们得手后将从中逃跑的门。赫尔姆斯、希尔和戴维斯穿着普通的衣服潜伏在小巷的阴影中，而拉特利夫则穿上了他的圣诞老人伪装。尽管做出了种种精心的策划，拉特利夫却没有考虑到这身衣服可能会吸引当地儿童的注意，当他从逃车走向银行时。他本以为这身伪装能让他融入圣诞节的购物人群中，
unlikely they would be required to shoot. The bank cashier, Alec Spears, was known to have said he would never risk being injured just to be a hero in a holdup. The group arrived in Cisco a little before midday. Ratliff directed Hill to park the Buick near the end of the alleyway, and pointed out the door they would escape through after obtaining their loot. Helms Hill and Davis lurked in the shadows of the alley, dressed in ordinary clothing, while Ratliff donned his Santa suit disguise. For all his intricate planning, Ratliff hadn't factored in the attention the suit might attract from local children as he strode from the getaway car to the bank. He thought the disguise would allow him to blend in with the Christmas shoppers,
但相反，它引起了许多不必要的关注。几个孩子跟着他进了银行，银行里比他预期的要繁忙得多。他仍然忠于自己的计划，等待着三个同伴的到来。由于害怕被认出声音，他拒绝回应出纳员亚历克·斯皮尔斯的问候。当其他人到达时，大劫案开始了，拉特利夫迅速开始往麻布袋里塞现金和债券，而其他人则在一旁放哨。希尔向一个正试图通过簿记员办公室逃跑的妇女和她的小女儿大喊，但他很快被外面的声音分散了注意力，停止了对她们逃跑的关注。
but instead it was drawing a lot of unwanted interest. Several of the children followed him into the bank, which was significantly busier than he had anticipated. Still committed to his plan, he awaited the arrival of his three accomplices. He refused to respond to the greeting given by the cashier, Alec Spears, out of fear he would recognise his voice. When the others arrived, the heist began, and Ratliff quickly got to work stuffing his burlap sack with cash and bonds while the others stood guard. Hill yelled at a woman and her young daughter who were making a break for it through the bookkeeper's office, but he was soon distracted from their escape by a noise outside.
一队当地人在银行门前排成整齐的封锁线，手里拿着枪。当第一声枪响时，暴徒们怒吼着涌向大楼。希尔向天花板开枪示警，希望能表明劫匪是武装且危险的，但他的警告枪声迎来了狂风暴雨般的枪击。当银行陷入混乱时，戴维斯多次中弹。赫姆发现两个小女孩——12岁的拉韦恩·科马和10岁的埃玛·梅·罗伯逊正蜷缩在柜台附近。他示意她们陪他进入出纳员后面的簿记员室。女孩们举起双手冲了过去，而其他劫匪则利用
A crew of local men had formed an orderly blockade in front of the bank with guns drawn. When the first gunshot rang out, the mob roared to life and descended on the building. Hill fired a volley of shots into the ceiling, hoping it would signify that the robbers were armed and dangerous, but his warning shots were met with a barrage of gunfire. Davis was struck multiple times as the bank descended into chaos. Helm spotted two young girls, 12-year-old Laverne Coma and 10-year-old MMA Robertson cowering near the counter. He motioned for them to accompany him into the bookkeeper's room behind the tellers. The girls put their hands up as they raced over, while the other robbers used
几个银行顾客充当人肉盾牌。许多平民在被推向后门时受了枪伤，拉特利夫也是如此，子弹的冲击力极强，导致他转了个身。为了保护卷入交火的无辜群众，警方下令义警暴徒停止射击。赫尔姆斯在两名年轻人质的掩护下从后门出现。他双手各挥舞着一把枪，同时开枪。拉特利夫从赫尔姆斯手中抢过拉韦恩和埃玛·梅，将她们塞进别克车。他很快认出年龄较大的是拉韦恩·科马，意识到自己必须继续穿着圣诞老人服装以免被认出。四个劫匪爬上车，
several of the bank's customers to create a human shield. Many of the civilians sustained gunshot wounds when they were rushed to the rear door, as did Ratliff, with the bullet having such a strong impact that it caused him to spin around. In order to protect the innocent people caught in the crossfire, police ordered the vigilante mob to cease fire. Helms emerged from the rear door shielded by his two young hostages. He brandished the gun in each hand, shooting both weapons at once. Ratliff grabbed Laverne and MMA from Helms and bundled them into the Buick. He soon recognised the older of the pair as Laverne Coma and realised he would have to continue wearing his Santa costume to avoid being identified. The four robbers climbed into the vehicle and took
逃之夭夭。贝德福德警察局长站在小巷中央向挡风玻璃开枪，市民们也紧追不舍。赫尔姆斯半个身子探出别克车窗，将枪对准贝德福德局长并扣动扳机，击中了他五次。随着别克车疾驰而去，思科主街上的枪声停了下来，目击者们开始评估损失。贝德福德警察局长和乔治·卡迈克尔警官身受重伤，六名市民严重受伤，其中包括银行出纳员亚历克斯·斯皮尔斯，他的下巴中枪。马里恩·奥尔森（Marion Olson，曾是劫匪人肉盾牌的一部分）以及顾客皮特·拉瑟福德（Pete Rutherford）、布雷迪·比格斯（Brady Biggs）和奥斯卡·克利（Oscar Clee）都受了枪伤。
off. Police Chief Bedford planted himself in the middle of the alleyway and shot at the windshield, as citizens also gave chase. Helms hoisted himself halfway out of the Buick's window, aimed his gun at Chief Bedford and pulled the trigger, hitting him five times. As the Buick sped away, the shooting along Cisco's main drag came to a stop and witnesses surveyed the damage. Police Chief Bedford and Officer George Carmichael lay mortally wounded, and six citizens were badly injured, including bank cashier Alex Spears, who had received a gunshot wound to the jaw. Marion Olson, who had been part of the robber's human shield, and customers Pete Rutherford, Brady Biggs and Oscar Clee had all sustained gunshot wounds.
银行千疮百孔，有200多处弹孔，使得无法确定这些伤势是由匪徒、警察还是赏金猎人暴徒造成的。由于抢先一步，别克车通常本可以甩掉大多数追赶它的车辆，但除了挡风玻璃外，该车的所有窗户都被震碎了，前保险杠也松动并卡在了车轴下。后座上嵌着两颗子弹，有一个轮胎完全瘪了。除了这些损坏，劫匪们很快意识到他们面临着另一个重大问题。由于该车已经行驶了数百英里，油箱现在已经
The bank was riddled with more than 200 bullet holes, making it impossible to determine whether the bandits, the police or the bounty hunting mob had been responsible for the injuries. Given a Ted start, the Buick would normally have outrun most of the vehicles that were pursuing it, but every one of the car's windows had been shattered except the windshield, and the front bumper had come loose and had jammed under the axle. Two bullets were embedded in the back seat, and one tire was completely flat. In addition to the damage, the robbers soon realized they were facing another major problem. Having already driven the vehicle for a couple of hundred miles, the fuel tank was now close to
见底了。他们不情愿地将车停在路边，并密谋再偷一辆。迎面驶来一辆崭新的奥尔斯莫比尔轿车，车里坐着哈里斯（Harris）一家，他们刚完成最后的圣诞购物准备返回镇上。拉特利夫仍然穿着他的圣诞老人服装，在路边疯狂挥手。出于节日精神，哈里斯一家将车停了下来。当车停稳后，拉特利夫举起枪管对准车上的乘客，命令他们投降。哈里斯一家照办了，他们下了车，逃离了现场。劫匪们将战利品和两名人质塞进奥尔斯莫比尔轿车。戴维斯伤势严重，
empty. They reluctantly pulled over to the side of the road and hatched a plan to steal another. Driving in the opposite direction was a brand new Oldsmobile that contained the Harris family, who were returning to town after completing some last-minute Christmas shopping. Ratliff, still in his Sanders suit, waved frantically from the side of the road. In the spirit of the season, the Harris's pulled over. When the vehicle came to a stop, Ratliff raised the barrel of a gun at its passengers and ordered them to surrender. The Harris family did as they were told, exiting their car and running from the scene. The robbers piled their loot and two hostages into the Oldsmobile. Davis was badly injured and
已经在别克车里昏迷不醒，于是男人们将他抬进他们的新逃跑车里。当希尔去拧动点火开关时，他发现钥匙不见了。在和家人逃跑之前，14岁的伍德罗·哈里斯（Woodrow Harris）拿走了钥匙并塞进了口袋，而劫匪们并没有察觉。劫匪中没有人懂得如何强行接通一辆崭新的奥尔斯莫比尔轿车的电路，于是他们匆忙返回别克车。他们没有时间把戴维斯抬回原车的车上，并且认为他已经濒死，便丢下他逃走了。三个劫匪希望剩下的汽油足够让他们拦截另一辆过往车辆。义警团赶到并包围了被遗弃的奥尔斯莫比尔轿车，
had passed out in the Buick, so the men carried him into their new getaway vehicle. When Hill went to turn on the ignition, he realized the keys were missing. Before escaping with his family, 14-year-old Woodrow Harris had snatched the keys and stuffed them into his pocket without the carjackers noticing. None of the robbers knew how to hotwire a brand new Oldsmobile, so they hastily returned to the Buick. They didn't have time to carry Davis back to the original car, and believing he was near death, they took off without him. The three robbers hoped there was enough gas remaining to allow them to intercept another passing vehicle. The vigilante group caught up and surrounded the abandoned Oldsmobile,
发现路易斯·戴维斯在后座上流血。雷迪斯警官决定取消警方追捕，以照顾受惊吓的哈里斯一家并将戴维斯逮捕。戴维斯被送到沃思堡医院，安置在底层一间靠近窗户的病房里，围观群众聚集在那里对指指点点。当他恢复意识时，警方要求他说出同伙的名字，否则警告他将被送上电椅，但戴维斯守口如瓶。几名武装市民继续追赶别克车，促使拉特利夫、赫尔姆斯和希尔向车窗外扔屋顶钉，以刺破
discovering Lewis Davis bleeding in the back seat. Officer Reddys decided to call off the police pursuit to tend to the traumatized Harris family and to place Davis under arrest. Davis was taken to Fort Worth Hospital and placed by the window in a ground floor room as crowds gathered to gawk at him. When he regained consciousness, the police demanded he reveal the names of his accomplices, warning he would be put to death in the electric chair otherwise, but Davis remained tight-lipped. Several armed citizens continued to chase after the Buick, prompting Ratliff, Helms and Hill to throw roofing nails out the car window to puncture
所有尾随车辆的轮胎。这三名男子随后决定步行会有更好的机会，于是拐进了一片牧场，并在灌木橡树、仙牙和牧豆树墙旁把车停了下来。他们命令年轻的人质从后座拿一个斜挎包，那个包太满太重，以至于女孩费力才能举起来。她们互相耳语说里面可能藏着偷来的黄金，而实际上里面装着几百发子弹。当拉特利夫、赫尔姆斯和希尔在车四周忙乱，收集所有需要的东西时，他们突然意识到把偷来的战利品——包括12,400美元现金和150,000美元
the tires of any vehicles following behind. The three men then decided they would have a better chance on foot and veered off into a pasture where they brought the car to a halt by a wall of scrub oak, cactus and mesquite. They ordered their young hostages to carry a satchel from the back seat, which was so full and heavy that the girl struggled to lift it. They whispered to one another that it might contain stolen gold, when in actuality had held hundreds of rounds of ammunition. As Ratliff, Helms and Hill scrambled around the car, gathering everything they needed, they suddenly realized they had left their stolen loot, including $12,400 in cash and $150,000
的证券——留在了奥尔斯莫比尔轿车的后座上，和戴维斯在一起。拉特利夫大声命令拉韦恩和戴玛·梅（Demma May）回到别克车里，趴在地板上，用手捂住眼睛，这样她们就看不到这三个男人逃进了哪片灌木丛。他警告说，如果她们偷看，他就会开枪。尽管如此，女孩还是偷偷瞥了一眼，看着满身是血、一瘸一拐的中心和他的两个同伴消失在夜色中。义警团的三名武装市民偶然发现了这辆撞毁的别克车，透过碎裂的车窗，他们看到了四只举起的手。他们满怀期待地举起枪，
in securities, in the back seat of the Oldsmobile with Davis. Ratliff barked at Laverne and Demma May to get back into the Buick and lie on the floor with their hands over their eyes so they couldn't see which direction the three men fled into the scrub. He warned that he would shoot them if they peaked. Regardless, the girl snuck a glance and watched as the bloodied and limping centre disappeared into the night with his two companions. Three armed citizens of the vigilante group came across the wrecked Buick and through its broken windows they spotted four raised hands. They lifted their guns in anticipation,
只听到车内传来拉韦恩和戴玛·梅惊恐的哭喊声。两人蜷缩在浸透血迹的车内地板上，但身体没有受伤。她们被带到警察局，拉韦恩在那里透露，她认出圣诞老人就是马歇尔·拉特利夫。她被告知将自己的怀疑烂在肚子里，这样警官们才有更大的机会抓住逃犯，然而在她回家后不久，谣言就传开了。思科的许多居民都认识马歇尔·拉特利夫，得知他参与了这起罪行并不感到惊讶。当局确定别克车是从威奇托县偷来的，在与当地警长交谈后，他们将目标锁定在亨利·赫尔姆斯身上，
only to hear the panicked voices of Laverne and Demma May crying out from inside the car. The pair were cowering on the floor of the blood-soaked vehicle but harboured no physical injuries. They were taken to the police station where Laverne revealed she had recognized Santa as being Marshal Ratliff. She was told to keep her suspicions to herself so that the officers had a better chance of trapping the fugitives, yet the rumours started almost immediately after she returned home. Many residents of Cisco had known Marshal Ratliff and were not surprised to learn of his involvement in the crime. Authorities determined that the Buick had been stolen from Wichita County and upon speaking to the local sheriff they zeroed in on Henry Helms
认为他是拉特利夫在逃的两个同伙之一。在平安夜，即劫案发生后的第二天，圣诞老人银行抢劫案的故事登上了邻镇东兰（Eastland）的当地报纸。记者博伊斯·豪斯（Boyce House）将这起事件描述为“西南历史上最壮观的犯罪，超过了比利小子（Billy the Kid）或詹姆斯兄弟（James Boys）所卷入的任何犯罪”。这起犯罪对当地社区产生了深远的影响，尤其是最年轻的成员，他们对圣诞老人能够犯下谋杀罪的想法感到恐惧。当一个穿着圣诞老人服装的男人当天晚些时候走进东兰拥挤的教堂时，会众中爆发出一声集体惊呼，一个小男孩问道：
as being one of Ratliff's two accomplices at large. On Christmas Eve, the day after the heist, the story of the Santa Claus bank robbery hit the local papers in the neighboring town of Eastland. Journalist Boyce House described the incident as quote, the most spectacular crime in the history of the southwest, surpassing any in which Billy the Kid or the James Boys had ever figured. The crime had a profound impact on the local community, especially its youngest members, who were left terrified by the idea that Santa was capable of committing murder. When a man in a Santa Claus suit entered a crowded Eastland church that same day, a collective gasper rose from the congregation and a young boy asked in
作为拉特利夫在逃的两名同谋之一。圣诞节前夕，即抢劫案发生的第二天，圣克劳斯银行抢劫案的故事上了邻近小镇伊斯特兰的当地报纸。记者博伊斯·豪斯将这起事件描述为“西南部历史上最壮观的犯罪，超过了比利小子或詹姆斯兄弟曾经参与的任何犯罪”。这起犯罪对当地社区产生了深远的影响，尤其是最年轻的成员，他们对圣诞老人会杀人这一想法感到恐慌。同一天，当一个穿着圣诞老人服装的男人走进拥挤的伊斯特兰教堂时，会众中发出了一声集体惊呼，一个小男孩问道
a tearful voice, Santa, why did you rob that bank? That evening, Lewis Davis succumbed to his injuries and died. The Santa Claus bank robbery had been his first and last brush with the law. The armed vigilantes who continued to seek out the now $15,000 bounty vowed to continue their hunt until the other three fugitives were brought to justice. Ratliff, Hill and Helms had spent the night after the robbery in the thick scrub near the location where they had ditched the Buick. Searches came within a few hundred feet of their hiding place, but failed to find the wanted men. In the morning, they stole another car and headed in the opposite direction to the search parties, managing to evade them for another
一个哭泣的声音：“圣诞老人，你为什么要抢劫那家银行？”那天晚上，刘易斯·戴维斯因伤重不治身亡。圣诞老人银行抢劫案是他生平第一次也是最后一次触犯法律。那些手持武器、继续追捕目前价值15,000美元悬赏金的自卫队成员誓言要继续搜寻，直到另外三名逃犯被绳之以法。拉特利夫、希尔和赫尔姆斯在抢劫案发生后的当晚，躲在他们丢弃别克汽车地点附近的浓密灌木丛中。搜寻人员曾一度逼近他们藏身处几百英尺的地方，但未能找到这些通缉犯。清晨，他们偷了另一辆车，朝着与搜寻队相反的方向驶去，设法又逃脱了
day. On Christmas Day, members of the vigilante group took a break and headed home to join their families for the festivities. The hunt resumed on Christmas night, with the group now joined by journalists and reporters, including Boyce House, who had initially broken the story. When sheriffs in surrounding towns heard that the fugitives might be heading in their direction, they assembled armed mobs to protect their communities. By Monday, December 26, more than a thousand citizens were participating in the search. Ratliff, Hill and Helms crashed their stolen vehicle near the small township of Putnam, 13 miles west of Cisco. There, they caught the attention of a father and his teenage son who
一天。圣诞节当天，自卫队成员休息并回家与家人共度节日。搜捕于圣诞节当晚恢复，除了最初报道这一新闻的博伊斯·豪斯等记者外，记者和通讯员也加入了搜捕队伍。当周边城镇的警长们听说逃亡者可能正朝他们的方向驶去时，他们组织了武装民兵来保护他们的社区。到12月26日星期一，已有上千名市民参与搜寻。拉特利夫、希尔和赫尔姆斯驾驶他们偷来的汽车在锡斯科以西13英里的小镇帕特南附近抛锚。在那里，他们引起了一对父子的注意，这两人
were driving past in a dodge and commandeered the vehicle. Overcome with pain, exhaustion and fear, the trio forced the teenager, Carl Wiley, to act as their driver, ordering his father out onto the road. As Carl drove off, his father pulled out a concealed pistol and shot at the car in an attempt to hit the assailants, only to shoot his son in the arm. Carl attempted to converse with his abductors, who had fallen quiet due to their deteriorating health. When the Dodgers gas tank was almost empty, Carl helped the trio find another appropriate car to steal. They settled on an old, poorly maintained Ford that was stocked with plenty of petrol. Once they secured the vehicle, they released Carl. Ratliff advised him to seek medical attention
正开着一辆道奇车路过，他们便强行占有了这辆车。在痛苦、疲惫和恐惧的驱使下，三人强迫十几岁的少年卡尔·威利作为他们的司机，并命令他的父亲下车站在路边。当卡尔开车离开时，他父亲掏出一把藏匿的手枪向汽车开枪，试图击中袭击者，结果却射中了自己儿子的手臂。卡尔试图与他的绑架者交谈，由于健康状况恶化，绑架者已经变得沉默寡言。当道奇车的油箱快要见底时，卡尔帮三人寻找另一辆适合偷窃的汽车。他们最终选中了一辆破旧失修、汽油充足的福特车。一旦他们拿到车，便释放了卡尔。拉特利夫劝他寻求医疗救助
for his arm and to make sure he told the authorities his own father had shot him and not them. At this point, Ratliff, Hill and Helms were under the impression that they kept true to their original plan by not killing anyone. They didn't realize that Chief Bedford had died shortly after the robbery or that his colleague, Officer George Carmichael, was in hospital, mortally injured. Carl agreed to tell the truth, including that the men had treated him fairly and bid them farewell and good luck. At 5am on December 27, Carl walked into the Cisco police station and asked for a doctor. He told officers that the robbers were heading towards Wichita Falls and that Ratliff and Hill were badly wounded, the former to the point of
治疗他的手臂，并确保告诉当局是他自己的父亲开枪打了他，而不是他们。此时，拉特利夫、希尔和赫尔姆斯还以为他们没有杀死任何人，从而坚守了最初的计划。他们并没有意识到贝德福德局长在抢劫案后不久就已经身亡，也没有意识到他的同事乔治·卡迈克尔警官正躺在医院里，伤势过重。卡尔同意说实话，包括这些对他们很好的人并向他们道别并祝他们好运。12月27日上午5点，卡尔走进锡斯科警察局要求找个医生。他告诉警察，抢劫犯正朝威奇托福尔斯方向逃窜，拉特利夫和希尔伤势严重，前者已经严重到
immobility. He doubted the group would last another 12 hours. The sheriff was unimpressed that Carl didn't take the opportunity to kill the weakened bandits while they slept, but as they had been good to him, the teenager didn't feel it would have been fair. Ratliff, Hill and Helms were penniless and considered robbing a store, but deemed it too risky. Helms was eager, but the feeble state of his two accomplices meant they would have little energy to run away. As they neared the Brazos River, the trio ditched the fort and stocked up on firearms and ammunition before making their way on foot or occasionally hands and knees across an oil field towards the woods by the river. Police set up an ambush at South Bend, an unincorporated community in Young
无法动弹。他怀疑这伙人撑不过另外12个小时。警长对卡尔没有趁虚弱的强盗睡觉时杀死他们感到不满，但由于他们对他很好，这位少年觉得那样做不公平。拉特利夫、希尔和赫尔姆斯身无分文，曾考虑抢劫一家商店，但认为风险太大。赫尔姆斯很急切，但他的两个同伙虚弱的状态意味着他们几乎没有力气逃跑。当他们接近布拉索斯河时，三人丢下了福特车，囤积了枪支和弹药，然后步行或偶尔手脚并用地穿过一片油田，走向河边的树林。警察在杨县的非建制社区南本德设下了埋伏，该社区位于布拉索斯河的一个弯曲处附近。
County located near a bend in the Brazos River. Certain the fugitives would soon pass through the area. Texas Ranger Cy Bradford was now involved in the hunt. He had a legendary reputation and according to some reports, he stood in the oil field with one cartridge in his shotgun and another two in his hand, certain that was all he needed to halt the offenders. When he caught sight of a weak and exhausted Marshal Ratliff across the field, Bradford aimed and pulled the trigger. He reloaded, then fired at Henry Helms. His final cartridge was spent at Robert Hill. All three shots hit their targets. Carrying six pistols and described as a walking arsenal, Marshal Ratliff was badly
确信逃犯很快会经过该地区。德克萨斯州游骑兵赛·布拉福德现在也加入了搜捕行动。他拥有传奇般的声誉，据一些报道称，他站在油田里，散弹枪里装了一发子弹，手里还拿了两发，确信这就是他制止罪犯所需的全部。当他在田野对面看到虚弱且筋疲力尽的马歇尔·拉特利夫时，布拉福德瞄准并扣动了扳机。他重新装弹，然后向亨利·赫尔姆斯开枪。他的最后一颗子弹打在了罗伯特·希尔身上。三枪全部命中目标。马歇尔·拉特利夫携带了六把手枪，被称为移动军火库，他伤势严重
injured and easy to capture. In total, he had sustained six gunshot wounds, including one to the jaw. After being shot by Ranger Bradford, Hill and Helms had managed to stagger into the nearby woodland by the river and disappeared out of sight. Despite wounded and without food, the pair survived and hid from search parties for two days, moving slowly under cover of the woods while an aeroplane scouted for them from above. Eventually, searches were able to track their footprints and early on the morning of Friday, December 30, Robert Hill and Henry Helms were finally captured in the north Texas city of Graham and taken into custody. By the time they were arrested, one week had passed since the men had entered the first
受伤且易于抓获。总共，他受到了六处枪伤，其中包括一处下巴中枪。在被布拉福德游骑兵射伤后，希尔和赫尔姆斯设法蹒跚走到河边附近的树林里，消失在视线之外。尽管受了伤且没有食物，两人还是在搜寻队的搜查下存活并躲藏了两天，在飞机从空中侦察的同时，借助树林的掩护缓慢移动。最终，搜寻人员追踪到了他们的足迹，12月30日星期五清晨，罗伯特·希尔和亨利·赫尔姆斯终于在德克萨斯州北部的格雷厄姆市被捕并被拘留。到他们被捕时，距离这伙人进入第一家银行已经过去了一周。
national bank in Cisco. The largest manhunt in Texas had finally come to an end. Officer George Carmichael succumbed to his injuries a week later on Saturday, January 7. The press were enthralled by the great Santa Claus robbery and journalist Boyce House's coverage of the crime propelled him to fame. He moved to Fort Worth, a city in north central Texas, where he built an illustrious career writing books, a syndicated column, and hosting his own radio program. He was twice nominated to run as the Democratic candidate for Lieutenant Governor of Texas, but lost both campaigns. 14-year-old Woodrow Harris, the teenager who slipped the ignition keys to his family's automobile into his pocket before they fled from the robbers,
锡斯科的国家银行。德克萨斯州历史上规模最大的搜捕行动终于落下帷幕。乔治·卡迈克尔警官在一周后的1月7日星期日伤重不治身亡。媒体对伟大的圣诞老人抢劫案着迷不已，记者博伊斯·豪斯对这起犯罪的报道使他一举成名。他搬到了德克萨斯州中北部城市沃斯堡，在那里他建立了辉煌的职业生涯，撰写书籍、联合专栏，并主持自己的广播节目。他曾两次被提名竞选德克萨斯州副州长的民主党候选人，但两次竞选均告失败。14岁的伍德罗·哈里斯（Woodrow Harris）是那个在家人从强盗手中逃跑之前，将自家汽车的点火钥匙塞进口袋的少年，
was presented with a gold pocket watch by the first national bank's insurance company to commemorate his heroism. The swift act led to the perpetrators accidentally leaving their loot behind and ultimately allowed the bank to recover all the stolen money. The cashier Alex Spears made a full recovery from his gunshot wound and eventually became president of the Cisco first national bank. He worked at the bank until he passed away in 1945. Ratliff Hill and Helms were each tried separately. Robert Hill represented himself and was sentenced to 99 years in prison for armed robbery. Throughout his incarceration he managed to escape three times. On his third attempt he left behind a note that read,
第一国民银行的保险公司向他颁发了一块金色怀表，以表彰他的英勇行为。这一迅捷的举动导致罪犯不小心落下了他们的战利品，并最终使银行找回了所有被盗资金。出纳员亚历克斯·斯皮尔斯从枪伤中完全康复，最终成为了锡斯科第一国民银行的行长。他在该行工作到1945年去世。拉特利夫、希尔和赫尔姆斯分别受审。罗伯特·希尔为自己辩护，因武装抢劫被判处99年监禁。在服刑期间，他设法逃跑了三次。在他的第三次尝试中，他留下了一张便条，上面写着：
If you want me you'll have to come to Paris, France. He made it as far as Houston, Texas, before he was recaptured. Back behind bars he decided life would be easier if he became a model prisoner and worked towards securing his release a more honest way. Marshall Ratliff was identified as the group's ringleader, but given that nobody had seen him fire a single shot he could only be convicted of armed robbery. He too was sentenced to 99 years in prison. Having expected to receive the death penalty Ratliff was delighted and felt he could do his time easily knowing that a model prisoner could be released from a life sentence in as little as 20 years. He told Texas Ranger Cy Bradford, That's no hill for a high stepper like me.
如果你想抓我，你得去法国巴黎。他一路逃到了德克萨斯州休斯顿，然后被重新抓获。回到铁窗后，他认为如果自己成为一名模范囚犯并以更诚实的方式争取获释，生活会更容易些。马歇尔·拉特利夫被认为是这伙人的头目，但鉴于没有人看到他开过一枪，他只能被判犯有武装抢劫罪。他也同样被判处99年监禁。由于预计会被判处死刑，拉特利夫感到很高兴，并觉得只要知道模范囚犯最快可在20年内从无期徒刑中获释，他就能轻松度过服刑期。他告诉德克萨斯州游骑兵赛·布拉福德：“对于像我这样的大步流星者来说，这不算什么山头。”
Henry Helms was identified as the shooter responsible for killing Cisco's chief of police GE Bit Bedford and his colleague officer George Carmichael and was sentenced to death by the electric chair. In an attempt to avoid the death penalty he immediately set about trying to convince everyone he was insane. Meanwhile the public was incensed that Marshall Ratliff appeared to be so pleased with his sentence and unrepentant for his crimes. They demanded he be tried again. The authorities agreed. During Ratliff's second trial the prosecution was still unable to find any witnesses willing to say they had seen him fire a single round. Regardless they found him guilty of involvement in the murders of police chief Bit Bedford and officer George Carmichael.
亨利·赫尔姆斯被认定为杀害锡斯科警察局长G·E·“比特”·贝德福德及其同事乔治·卡迈克尔警官的枪手，并被判处电椅死刑。为了逃避死刑，他立即着手试图让所有人相信他疯了。与此同时，公众对马歇尔·拉特利夫似乎对自己的判解感到满意且对罪行毫无悔意感到愤怒。他们要求对他的案件重新审判。当局同意了。在拉特利夫的第二次审判期间，控方仍然找不到任何愿意作证说看到他开过一枪的证人。无论如何，他们还是判定他参与谋杀警察局长“比特”·贝德福德和乔治·卡迈克尔警官罪名成立。
Ratliff was sentenced to join Helms on death row. Despite Helms putting on a convincing show for the court his insanity plea fell on deaf ears. On Friday September 6, 1929, nearly two years after the Santa Claus robbery Henry Helms was dragged kicking and screaming to his execution in the electric chair. Once again Marshall Ratliff's mother attempted to come to her incarcerated son's aid by submitting that he was criminally insane. Ratliff spent his time in prison studying the behaviors of the mentally disordered and became convinced that he could succeed in convincing the authorities that he was not of sound mind and thus unable to be put to death. While awaiting his insanity hearing, Ratliff
拉特利夫被判处与赫尔姆斯一起加入死囚牢房。尽管赫尔姆斯在法庭上表现得很有说服力，但他的精神失常辩护并未被采纳。1929年9月6日星期五，在圣诞老人抢劫案发生近两年后，亨利·赫尔姆斯被拖着踢打尖叫着送上电椅执行死刑。马歇尔·拉特利夫的母亲再次试图通过提交他精神错乱的申诉来帮助她被监禁的儿子。拉特利夫在狱中花时间研究精神失常者的行为，并坚信自己能成功让当局相信他精神不正常，因此无法被处决。在等待精神失常听证会期间，拉特利夫
complained of paralysis and the prison guards had to physically lift him up out of bed to feed him. 53-year-old deputy sheriff Tom Jones was a father of eight who took on the responsibility of caring for Ratliff by feeding and bathing him as well as assisting him to use the bathroom. By Monday November 18, 1929, Ratliff had remained completely motionless for 10 days. Convinced he was unable to move, the guards became sloppy in their security measures. That night, as deputy sheriff Jones and his colleague Pack Kilbourne prepared to feed Ratliff, the pair left the door to his cell open. In reality, he had been faking the symptoms of paralysis all along and slipped out of his cell and snuck downstairs to the sheriff's office,
抱怨瘫痪，狱警不得不把他从床上扶起来喂饭。53岁的副警长汤姆·琼斯是八个孩子的父亲，他承担起照顾拉特利夫的责任，喂他吃饭、给他洗澡以及协助他上厕所。到1929年11月18日星期日，拉特利夫已经连续10天保持完全一动不动。坚信他无法动摇，警卫们在安保措施上变得松懈。那天晚上，当副警长琼斯和他的同事帕克·基尔本准备给拉特利夫喂食时，两人把他的牢房门开着。事实上，他一直在伪装瘫痪的症状，并溜出牢房，偷偷下楼到警长办公室，
where he found a pistol on the desk. Ratliff then attempted to break free, but was soon warded by a locked door. He returned to the office to search for keys, and along the way he encountered deputy sheriff Jones coming down the stairs. Ratliff raised the gun and shot at the deputy three times, once in the stomach, once above his left knee, and once above the heart, causing life-threatening injuries. When Pack Kilbourne heard the sound of gunfire, he came running, and Ratliff shot at him too. The shots missed, and Pack tackled him to the ground. As the two men struggled, they both fired their pistols at one another, but their bullets kept missing their marks.
在那里他在桌上找到了一把手枪。拉特利夫随后试图逃跑，但很快被一扇锁着的门挡住。他回到办公室寻找钥匙，在路上遇到了正下楼的副警长琼斯。拉特利夫举起枪向副警长开枪三次，一次击中腹部，一次击中左膝上方，一次击中心脏上方，造成了致命伤。当帕克·基尔本听到枪声时，他跑了过来，拉特利夫也向他开枪。子弹打偏了，帕克把他扑倒在地。两人在搏斗时互相向对方开枪，但子弹一直没有击中目标。
As the scuffle continued, Pack's daughter Mesa raced into the room and aimed her own gun at Ratliff. Other officers quickly arrived and restrained Mesa before she could take a shot and risk hitting her father. Pack struck Ratliff over the head with his gun, sending him into a daze, then pressed a knee on his prisoner to hold him down. He aimed his pistol directly at Ratliff's head and pulled the trigger. However, the gun was out of bullets, sparing Ratliff, who was taken back to his cell. Deputy Sheriff Jones was beloved in his community, and when the news spread that Ratliff had caused him serious injury, the townspeak was sent into a vengeful frenzy.
随着扭打继续，帕克的女儿梅莎冲进房间，用自己的枪对准了拉特利夫。其他警官迅速赶到，在梅莎开枪并冒着击中她父亲的风险之前控制住了她。帕克用枪击打拉特利夫的头部，使他陷入眩晕，然后用膝盖压住囚犯将其按倒在地。他用手枪直接对准拉特利夫的头部并扣动了扳机。然而，枪里已经没有子弹了，这饶了拉特利夫一命，他被带回了牢房。副警长琼斯在社区里备受爱戴，当拉特利夫给他造成重伤的消息传开后，镇上的人们陷入了复仇的狂热之中。
On November 19, 1929, the day after Ratliff's botched escape, a horde of approximately 2,000 men, women, and children descended on the Eastland Jail where he was imprisoned. A majority of the crowd came from Cisco, but people had also joined from neighboring and far away towns. Pack Kilbourne didn't believe in mob justice and stood at the door of the jail, pleading with the crowd to go away and let the courts do their job. An enraged mob of 200 men overpowered Pack and seized Ratliff, stripping him naked and dragging him outside. They carried him past the Majestic Theatre, where a production called The Noose was playing, and came to a stop on a well-lit Main Street. One man tied a hemp-robed noose and secured it
1929年11月19日，即拉特利夫越狱失败的第二天，大约2,000名男女老少蜂拥至他被关押的伊斯特兰监狱。人群大多来自锡斯科，但也有来自邻近和遥远城镇的人。帕克·基尔本不相信私刑正义，他站在监狱门口，恳求人群离开，让法庭做它们该做的事。200名愤怒的暴徒制服了帕克，抓走了拉特利夫，剥光了他的衣服并把他拖到外面。他们把他抬过正在上演名为《绞索》剧目的富丽堂皇剧院，在灯光明亮的主街上停了下来。一个人用大麻绳打了个绞索并将其固定
around Ratliff's neck. The length of the rope was tossed over a nearby utility pole, while a dozen men took hold and hoisted Ratliff into the air. The jerk of the rope was so violent that it broke and sent Ratliff tumbling to the ground. Members of the mob held him down until another rope could be retrieved. When asked if he had any final words, Ratliff mumbled incoherently. Displeased, the crowd started chanting, string him up, string him up. Ratliff was raised, slower this time, and just before his feet left the ground, he offered his final words. Forgive me, boys. In the 1920s, lynchings were not completely unheard of in Texas. However, Eastland was considered a progressive area, and its residents claimed that this was the county's
在拉特利夫的脖子上。绳子的一端被抛过附近的一根公用电线杆，十几个人抓住绳子把拉特利夫拉到了空中。绳子的猛烈拉拽将其扯断，导致拉特利夫摔倒在地上。暴徒成员将他按倒在地，直到找来另一根绳子。当被问及是否有遗言时，拉特利夫含糊不清地嘟囔着。人群感到不满，开始高呼：“吊死他，吊死他。”拉特利夫被再次拉起，这次速度较慢，就在他的脚离开地面之前，他留下了最后的遗言：“原谅我，伙计们。”在20世纪20年代，私刑在德克萨斯州并非闻所未闻。然而，伊斯特兰被认为是一个进步地区，当地居民声称这是该县
first lynching since 1888. The last one on record had resulted in the hanging of a notorious horse thief. Three years prior to that, two young men who were crucial witnesses in a pending court case had also been lynched in the county. After Ratliff was hanged, his body remained on display for several hours until a justice of the peace ordered him to be cut down. It was then taken and put on display in an Eastland furniture store, where several thousand people stopped by to view it, before his family came to take possession. When Pat Kilbaugh told Deputy Sheriff Tom Jones that he had tried his best to stop the lynching, Jones nodded and allegedly whispered, that's good, I'm glad they did it. Others have claimed they heard him say,
自1888年以来的第一起私刑。有记录的最后一起私刑导致了一名臭名昭著的偷马贼被绞死。在此之前三年，两名在未决法庭案件中至关重要的年轻证人也在该县遭到私刑处死。拉特利夫被绞死后，他的尸体被公开展示了几个小时，直到治安法官下令将他放下。随后，尸体被带到伊斯特兰的一家家具店公开展示，数千人驻足观看，直到他的家属前来领回尸体。当帕特·基尔鲍夫告诉副警长汤姆·琼斯他已尽力阻止私刑时，琼斯点点头，据称低声说道：“很好，我很高兴他们这么做了。”其他人则声称听到他说：
that's bad, they shouldn't have done it. At 11am on Wednesday November 20, 1929, Deputy Sheriff Tom Jones died from the wounds he sustained at the hands of Marshall Ratliff. He was the sixth and final death arising from the Santa Claus bank robbery that occurred almost two years earlier. An investigation into the lynching was launched, but resulted in no arrests. A marker observing the event was eventually placed on the utility pole in Eastland County where Ratliff was hanged. Nobody was able to claim that bankers dead Robert Bounty for Ratliff, but several people came forward to declare they had been the ones to shoot Louis Davis. Rumors spread that the Texas Bankers Association was encouraging as many people as possible to
“太糟糕了，他们不该这么做。”1929年11月20日星期三上午11点，副警长汤姆·琼斯因马歇尔·拉特利夫造成的伤势身亡。他是近两年前发生的圣诞老人银行抢劫案导致的第六位也是最后一位死者。针对私刑的调查随即展开，但没有导致任何人被逮捕。最终，一个纪念该事件的标志牌被放置在拉特利夫被绞死的伊斯特兰县公用电线杆上。没有人能够声称银行家为拉特利夫死了发放了赏金，但几个人挺身而出，宣称自己才是开枪打死刘易斯·戴维斯的人。有传言称，德克萨斯州银行家协会正在鼓励尽可能多的人
come forward in order to muddy the waters, which would mean they could avoid having to make any payments. Ultimately, nobody was allowed to claim a bounty of any kind in relation to the Santa Claus robbery. The only surviving bandit, Robert Hill, succeeded in becoming a model prisoner and was released in 1948 after serving the minimum of 20 years. He changed his name, got married, moved to a small town in West Texas and went on to live a quiet, uneventful life until his death in 1996 at the age of 90. The first National Bank of Cisco remained at the same location on Main Street for the rest of the century. It eventually grew in size and was replaced by a more modern building that remained next to the alleyway where the 1927 shootout had
站出来以搅浑水，这意味着他们可以避免支付任何赔偿金。最终，没有人被允许领取与圣诞老人抢劫案有关的任何悬赏金。唯一的幸存强盗罗伯特·希尔成功成为一名模范犯人，在服满最低20年的刑期后于1948年获释。他改了名字，结了婚，搬到了德克萨斯州西部的一个小镇，过着平静安稳的生活，直到1996年以90岁高龄去世。锡斯科第一国民银行在世纪剩下的时间里一直留在主街的原址上。它最终规模扩大，并被一栋更现代的建筑所取代，该建筑仍然毗邻1927年枪战发生的
occurred. The back door where the bandits escaped became the drive-through deposit window. A mural of the robbery was placed in the lobby, becoming a popular tourist attraction. Since August 2009, the bank building has been occupied by an auto parts store, but the Texas Historical Commission placed a medallion at the site that reads, Scene of Daring Santa Claus Bank Robbery, December 23, 1927 There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
小巷。强盗们逃跑时的后门变成了免下车存款窗口。大厅里挂着一幅抢劫案的壁画，成为了一个受欢迎的旅游景点。自2009年8月以来，该银行大楼一直被一家汽车零件商店占据，但德克萨斯州历史委员会在该地点放置了一块牌匾，上面写着：“1927年12月23日，胆大包天的圣诞老人银行抢劫案现场。”本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。